hello there Guardians and welcome to
reality check so how many of you have
been donning your space cloaks and
blasting your way around the solar
system and bungees latest offering
destiny if you have been then your quest
to rid the solar system of the alien
force threatening to extinguish mankind
should result in some pretty scenic stop
offs around our solar system namely the
moon Mars and of course Venus but not
quite as we know them today they have
all been made livable terraformed by
mankind but what if you were to actually
visit these places today how do the
celestial playgrounds of destiny
compare to the real-life environments
and you know this topic is kind of
perfect for the show reality check
because the game is sci-fi and this show
is about science in fact you might say
that making this episode is is is my job
welcome to your solar system centuries
from that long since Earth's golden ages
ended long since we colonized our
neighboring planets mysterious darkness
destiny takes place 700 years in the
future everything has gone a bit
post-apocalyptic following a previous
period of prosperous exploration known
as the Golden Age during this time of
Plenty and technological advancement
mankind successfully terraformed and
colonized its three closest celestial
neighbors with help from the mysterious
traveler a giant city sized floating
sphere thing you can get a close look at
the destiny versions of Venus Mars and
the moon by either you know playing the
game or alternatively by jumping onto
your space internet browsers in space
navigating your way to WWE planet view
comm it's a Google Streetview kind of an
experience produced by the game makers
but nonetheless are a great way to cast
your eye over some of the environments
and if you check out Destiny's take on
Venus as well as the ruins of previous
civilizations you can't help but notice
the jungles yep beautiful tropical green
jungles that means we can assume in
oxygen-rich atmosphere surface
temperatures averaging around 30 degrees
Celsius and similar air pressure to
earth the one of our real world Venus
well if you were to be instantly
transported to the surface right now
what would you experience well for
starters it's a little hotter than it
isn't destiny Venus has an average
temperature of 460 degrees C that's hot
enough to melt lead by the way making it
by far the hottest planet in our solar
system yep hotter than mercury even
though that guy is closer to the Sun why
well because of Venus's thick atmosphere
of co2 this runaway greenhouse effect
traps almost all the heat radiated away
from the surface further warming the
planet the whole of Venus is basically
wrapped in a super thick duvet this also
results in an intense surface pressure
of 91 atmospheres so that's 91 times the
pressure on the surface of Earth that's
roughly the same as you'd find 1,000
meters beneath the surface of the
Pacific Ocean
also the clouds and Venus are so thick
that the only way to really see through
them is to use radar imaging oh and rain
sulfuric acid a lot yep there's also the
bizarre fact that a day on Venus is
actually longer than a year yep you
heard me correctly now as extreme as
these conditions are though it hasn't
stopped mankind landing on the planet's
surface not with a person mind you dear
God no that would be cruel however the
Soviet Union did send a number of space
probes which successfully landed and
even captured photos of the planet's
surface
although the craft only lasted a couple
of hours before you know melting
okay now it's time for the Red Planet
now in the world of the real Mars is no
holiday destination surface temperatures
vary from a damn chilly minus 143
degrees C at the winter polar caps to
highs of up to 35 degrees C at the
equator there is also no magnetic field
which combined with a wather thin
atmosphere results in dangerous levels
of ionizing radiation bombarding the
surface and to add insult to injury what
des pass for an atmosphere on Mars is
composed almost entirely of co2 with
just a whiff of oxygen 0.16% by the way
all this makes Mars a decidedly
inhospitable place when you first make
planet full and destiny however you
might conclude that not much has changed
as with Venus there are signs of human
colonization during the aforementioned
Golden Age but in terms of environment
you might conclude that Mars doesn't
look that drastically different it's
still red due to the hematite dust
covering the planet's surface rust
essentially but on closer inspection it
is clearly a changed place crucially
there is plant life on the ground now
this would be impossible on the real
Martian surface due to all the ionizing
radiation so some pretty intense
terraforming must have taken place
increasing the thickness of the
atmosphere and also altering its
chemical makeup to include much more
oxygen okay finally let's take a look at
the Earth's closest celestial buddy our
very own satellites the moon the actual
factual challenges facing any lunar
visitors basically come down to the next
to non-existent atmosphere this means
that surface temperatures are entirely
dependent on exposure to the Sun during
the day they can rise as high as 123
degrees Celsius and at night drop as low
as minus 233 in destiny land as with
Mars the moon looks very similar to what
we are used to in real life aside from
the old habitation buildings littering
the surface
unlike Mars however there appears to be
no indigenous life or anything growing
on the surface at all suggesting more
limited terraforming there does appear
however to be more of an atmosphere this
can be seen as your craft comes into
land
look clearly clients from what I can
tell though this does seem to be the
only major change in the environment on
the moon making it the most similar to
real life of all location as your
journey to in destiny so then let me
know what you thought of this week's
reality check
do you remember though that a lot of
this is based on supposition and
guesswork because it's not as if Bungie
of release specifications of their
celestial destinations so I've done my
best job but if you think I've missed
anything or made a mistake do you let me
know in the comments down below or by
hitting me up on Twitter at scam Fras
Robb already guys thanks for watching
see you next week